Britt: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find all the differences
between McDonald's in
the US and Australia.
This is "Food Wars."
Before we get started,
I wanted to introduce our new host, Britt.
She is going to be our "Food
Wars" expert down in Australia,
and I hope you guys love
her as much as I do.
She is lovely.
In the US, our fries come in four sizes,
kids, small, medium, and large.
In Australia, our fries come
in three different sizes,
small, medium, and large.
Nico: Let's weigh our largest fry.
I am so impressed by
this stack, by the way.
This is a masterpiece.
Wow.
Get a load of that stack of fries.
Very impressive.
That's it for me, bye!
What about the iconic Big Mac?
Let's weigh it.
Some of our burger options
come in different sizes to the US.
We have a single cheeseburger,
a double cheeseburger,
and a triple cheeseburger.
Over here, the standard
McDonald's cheeseburger
only comes in two sizes,
the single or the double.
Our McDonald's drinks come in four sizes,
extra small, which we could not get,
small, medium, and large.
Our drinks in Australia
come in three sizes,
small, medium, and large.
12 fluid ounces is the
size of a can of Coke,
so it's so wild to me that that is
the smallest size of beverage
you can get at McDonald's.
Let's measure our largest drink.
Our largest drink came
out to 800 milliliters
when we're supposed to be getting 946.
That is egregious!
That's so, so unfair!
Producer: It's not even 600!
It's not even 600, but what number is it?
So, our large is coming
at 520 milliliters.
650 to 520 is a massive difference.
Daylight robbery.
Chicken nuggets in the
US come in five sizes,
a four-piece, a six-piece, a 10-piece,
a 20-piece, and a 40-piece.
Our chicken nuggets come in five sizes.
We have a three-piece,
a six-piece, a 10-piece,
a 20-piece, and a 40-piece.
Finally, another country
matches us with the 40-piece!
It's only taken us two years
of "Food Wars" to find one.
Here is everything at
an Australian McDonald's
you won't find in the US.
Here's everything at a US McDonald's
you won't find in Australia.
There are a lot of things over here
that you can't find in the
States, like these socks.
We're going to break
them down into categories
and go through them all.
I really need to try these socks on
because they are amazing.
Look at that. Fashion, fun.
I'm going to feel like a
criminal with these bad boys.
Hamburglar.
Starting with the beef burgers,
we have a classic Angus;
a barbecue bacon Angus;
a spicy, sticky barbecue Angus;
we have a triple cheeseburger;
big brekkie burger,
which I just couldn't resist
and I really needed to try that.
And then we have a McFeast,
and then we finish off
with the double Big Mac.
It's massive.
I think you taste more
meat than the actual sauce
with the combination of the meat.
I think just a regular
Big Mac is probably better
because you get more flavor.
So, if you look at these
burgers that we have here,
this Angus looks a little bit
more premium than the others.
I definitely think there's
a culture in Australia
that really enjoys high-quality
beef, high-quality burgers,
which is why these do so well here.
Here are the exclusive burger options.
We have a McDouble, my favorite,
and then we have two Quarter
Pounders with cheese.
One just has bacon on it.
I think what makes it different
than a double cheeseburger
is that the double cheeseburger
has two slices of cheese and no ketchup.
Confirm or deny that right here for me.
The McDouble also has thinner patties,
which I prefer to the thicker ones.
Moving on, I do want to try
one of the Quarter Pounders.
I'm going for the one with
bacon in it, because obviously.
This looks like a perfect little burger.
You could be in commercials!
Mm, that's good!
So, this is the Quarter
Pounder deluxe with cheese.
Next, let's take a look at
our chicken and fish options
we have over here.
First and starting strong,
we have a deluxe chicken.
It's a grilled chicken
with lettuce, tomato, mayo.
It's aioli.
And moving on, we have our McSpicy.
Smells peppery.
It's got a bit of a kick,
but I wouldn't say that it's ...
oh, oh, it's the afterkick. It gets spicy.
Oh, my gosh, it's creeping up on me.
I actually really like this.
Next one is the double McChicken.
This is a heavy burger. Two
pieces of chicken on it.
You're not missing out on this in America.
Thumbs down, mm-mm.
While we're talking about chicken,
we have a bunch of chicken
wraps here in Australia,
starting with the Caesar
grilled chicken McWrap,
and we have a Caesar
crispy chicken McWrap.
We have an aioli grilled chicken McWrap,
another aioli crispy chicken McWrap,
and then we have a grilled
chicken snack wrap.
And we were supposed to have a wholemeal,
but there was no
wholemeal wraps available.
Let's try
the aioli grilled chicken McWrap.
That's really good.
It's really light.
Approved.
I wouldn't mind having a look
at the crispy chicken Caesar wrap.
The chicken inside as
well look really good.
It's staring me down.
It's better than the other
one, the aioli chicken.
Burst of flavor in your mouth.
Moving on to our chicken options,
we have the spicy McCrispy,
the spicy McCrispy deluxe,
and the regular McCrispy deluxe.
I think that "deluxe" in
McDonald's terminology
just means it has
lettuce and tomato on it.
So, this is the spicy McCrispy.
That is really good, and
it's actually so spicy.
And finally, we have the
following salad options:
classic chicken salad,
and then we also have a Caesar salad,
and we have a garden salad
that looks really sad.
It's quite tragic, actually.
Little seasoning for the Caesar salad.
I don't really care about a salad.
McDonald's US used to serve salads,
but they started disappearing from menus
during the pandemic
and have not reemerged.
I for one do not miss them.
I'm not going to McDonald's for a salad.
If I wanted a salad, I'd just
go to a salad place. You know?
Australians can, of course,
enjoy McDonald's iconic Happy Meals,
including some things you
won't find in America.
The grilled chicken snack
wrap, grape tomatoes,
a Pop Top, which is an
apple juice equivalent.
Imagine if you were a kid
and you were like, "Mom,
take me to Macca's,"
and you drove past and she gave you this.
I like the healthy option,
but you'd be absolutely devastated.
That is punishment. That is awful.
And a little toy.
Spot It! Classic.
Spot what exactly?
Is this like ... what is this?
This is too complicated for me.
How would this ... this is really boring.
I would hate this if I was a kid.
No. Give me a Tamagotchi or something.
I don't know. What you give kids? Like ...
Kids in the US are limited to
just a hamburger or nuggets
plus fries and apple slices.
One thing I thought was interesting
is that you can't get a soda
with the Happy Meal anymore.
They only really give you
juice options or milk,
which is what I have here.
Our Happy Meal theme is "Crash Bandicoot,"
which I haven't seen since I was a child.
I think I had this game
on, like, Nintendo 64.
It's very old,
but I think it's, like, a new mobile game
collaboration that they're doing.
I do want to see what my toy is.
Spyro's Memory Card Game.
It's a memory card game.
That's not that good.
I feel like the toys
have really gone downhill
since I was a kid.
We used to get stuff. Like, good stuff.
Wait, is this a card game or no?
What?
Oh, my God, it's like a little ...
oh, it's a tin.
The cards are in the tin.
That's actually kind of cute.
This is not going to
satisfy the iPad kids.
They're going to put this in the garbage.
So, here's our little card game.
It is kind of cute that they made the box
a little "Crash Bandicoot" crate.
That's fun.
That's the Happy Meal in the US.
Here are the exclusive sides from Macca's.
We have some McDonaldland cookies
and a Petit Miam strawberry yogurt.
We do also have the mozzarella
sticks with chili jam.
However, they were out
of stock of that today.
Oh, my gosh, this smell
reminds me of my childhood.
Can I pour this? I'm going to pour this.
You've got Ronald McDonald,
duck with glasses on.
I'm sure that's someone.
They're hard cookies.
But generally in Australia
our cookies are generally quite hard.
I don't know why, but they're delicious.
We actually don't have any sides in the US
that you can't also find in Australia.
The one thing I wish that we had
that Australia has is
those mozzarella sticks.
I would devour some
mozzarella sticks right now.
It's that time.
It's sauce talk.
Sauce talk.
We actually don't have very
many sauces to talk about.
I have ranch, plain mustard,
and we're missing a
regular packet of honey.
I'm not really sure why they
have honey as a sauce option.
Like, what do you use that for?
I guess you could use it on the biscuits.
I know what ranch tastes like.
I know what mustard tastes like.
We don't have to talk about it anymore.
Sauce talk is over.
Here are the Aussie exclusive sauces.
We have a wasabi-flavored mayo,
a truffle-flavored mayo, aioli
sauce, and sweet mustard.
All right, let's try them.
So, this is the aioli.
Yum.
Quite garlicky as well.
So, this is the sweet mustard.
It's just not a bit of me.
But yeah, aioli is a classic here.
Anything with garlic,
anything with a really strong flavor
that makes people want
to stay far away from you
when you speak and breathe, we're onto it.
If you actually manage to
wake up in time for breakfast,
then you'll find a ton of
exclusive breakfast items
here in the US.
McDonald's actually did do
an all-day breakfast menu,
which was revolutionary.
Lives were changed.
And then in March of 2020 they stopped,
and we went back to breakfast until 11.
11 doesn't sound like
that early of a time,
but for me, yeah, it is.
And in the US, you can obviously
get your breakfast sandwich
on a variety of vessels, like the biscuit.
We also have the McGriddle,
which is essentially two little pancakes
with a bunch of syrup holes.
So the syrup is already
incorporated into the pancake bun.
And whoever thought of this as a sandwich,
something special happened,
something shifted,
because this is one of the greatest things
I've ever seen and tasted.
We don't have that here,
but I can't say I'm particularly jealous.
The idea of having syrupy pancakes
as a bun with meat is just a bit weird.
However, I know that you
guys rave on about it,
so I'd be really, really
inclined to try it
because I'd want to know
how it would actually taste.
There's also the McMuffin,
which is an English muffin.
There's also a variety
of different proteins
that you can get in
your breakfast sandwich.
Like, I'm seeing ham, bacon, sausage,
and now steak, which was a shock to me.
I didn't hear anything about McDonald's
adding steak to its breakfast
menu, but we got it.
Let's start with this steak biscuit.
In my brain, when I saw the
steak on the menu, I was like,
wow, they're doing little bits of steak.
That's actually so impressive.
This is a burger patty in
a breakfast-sandwich form.
It doesn't taste bad.
This is my favorite McGriddle.
It's the bacon, egg, and cheese.
All those little dark spots,
those are the syrup holes.
These are always going to hit for me.
They're good.
This is the McMuffin with
Canadian bacon, cheese, and egg.
The egg on this one is a
little different than the rest.
It's supposed to be a freshly cracked egg.
I wasn't in the room when this was made,
so I can't speak on that.
But it looks different than
the folded egg, obviously.
That was a little tough.
And lastly, we have the sausage burrito.
That's pretty good, I'm not gonna lie.
Moving on to the breakfast meals.
These are bigger portions.
There's more stuff involved,
it's not just a quick little sandwich.
We have the Big Breakfast.
There's the Big Breakfast with hotcakes,
which comes with all of that
stuff, plus some hotcakes.
There's the hotcakes with a sausage patty.
And all the hotcake meals come with
whipped butter and syrup.
Duh.
The hotcakes at McDonald's
are a little ...
they taste kind of fake,
like they don't taste like real pancakes,
but I'm a big fan of them.
I don't know, there's
something very nostalgic
about the hotcakes for me.
We also have the fruit and maple oatmeal,
which comes with fruit
and I am assuming maple
already incorporated into the oatmeal.
Let's pour these in.
OK, this actually smells really good.
Am I just hungry?
It's a good oatmeal.
I would order that again.
It doesn't taste too sweet.
And the parts that are sweet are fruit,
so I don't really feel bad eating it.
We only have a couple of
exclusive breakfast
bites here in Australia.
We have the mighty McMuffin
or the big brekkie burger.
If you can see, two patties,
onion, and a hash brown, cheese, egg.
I don't think my mouth is going
to open up wide enough to...
All right, I'm slightly intimidated.
That is so good.
Unreal. I recommend that.
So, now we have the mighty McMuffin.
It's not a regular McMuffin.
It's better than that.
It's not as flavorful as this.
This is a subtle explosion,
not a full earthquake.
This is ... I'm going to have another bite
because I actually really like it.
So, here we have all of our
McCafé exclusive drinks.
First up we have the iced
French vanilla latte,
which sounds very good.
It's sweet. That is very sweet.
They're giving Dunkin'
a run for their money.
It doesn't taste bad because
it's a French vanilla coffee,
but that's way too sweet for me.
We also have that latte hot.
Next, there's the iced
French vanilla coffee,
which, I actually might like this more.
Yeah, this one is way better to me.
It actually tastes more
like coffee and not milk.
Next we have a caramel cappuccino.
This is a vanilla cappuccino,
and we have the iced caramel macchiato.
Let's try the caramel cappuccino.
I'm not a huge fan of
the taste of this one.
We're missing the
Americano and the frappé,
which I've had before. It is very sweet.
You'll find Macca's McCafé items
in both the US and Australia,
but the offerings are pretty different.
So, these are our McCafé drinks.
We have our long black,
which is basically an
Americano but better.
And we have our English
breakfast tea, our Earl Grey tea.
We have a green tea, a
peppermint tea, a piccolo latte,
and a little babyccino.
I'm really jealous of
those cute little coffees
that you have in Australia.
I want that little tiny baby cup.
We have our iced long black,
our deluxe crème brûlée,
which is iced and not here.
And we also have our iced
chocolate, a coffee frappé,
a deluxe caramel iced coffee.
We have also a deluxe
hazelnut iced coffee.
And then last but not least,
our vanilla deluxe iced coffee.
I really want to try this iced chocolate.
That's not going to be
good for my stomach,
but this is really good.
It's like a cocoa powder chocolate flavor.
Like, it's not too rich.
Teas at Macca's.
I don't know anyone that would get a tea.
I mean, unless you're,
like, a British expat.
I want to try peppermint tea because ...
Did they put milk in
my peppermint tea too?
What?
Why would you put milk in a herbal tea?
Oh, that's putrid.
Did you know that McCafé was
actually created in Australia
in Melbourne in 1993?
The first café was opened
in Swanston Street, I'm pretty sure.
We pride ourselves on our coffee,
especially people in Melbourne.
Without Melbourne or Australia,
you wouldn't be having McCafé.
So, thank you.
I will take all the glory.
This is our McCafé food.
We have a barbecue,
bacon, and cheese toastie,
which we don't have here.
We have a ham and cheese toastie.
We have a cheese and tomato toastie.
We have a cheesy toastie.
Banana bread with blueberries.
We really like banana bread here.
And then just your plain banana bread.
We usually stock raisin toast with butter,
but they were out of stock for that today.
We have our double-chocolate muffin
and apple crumble muffin.
We also have a chocolate doughnut.
And because we like to
keep it a little bit fancy,
we have a chocolate macaron
and we also have a salted caramel macaron.
Australians, we really love our caramel.
Salted caramel, normal caramel.
We have it with everything.
That's a really nice salted caramel.
Good job, Macca's.
Another thing we're missing
here in the US McCafé
is the food.
Those are all gone from the
menu, and we have a theory.
We have a theory that it's because
they're opening up their
new CosMc's restaurant,
which is I guess a McCafé
turned into a restaurant.
It's going to be, like, bakery items
and coffees and just that.
If you want to end your Macca's
meal with a sweet treat,
we have some exclusive
dessert options for you,
starting off with a Milo McFlurry.
There was supposed to be a Malteser,
but they were all out of them.
So we got the better
option, which is Milo.
If you don't know what Milo is,
Milo is an Australian classic.
You can put it in your drinks,
you can put it on ice cream.
It's just a chocolate
powder that is so good.
We didn't have a
raspberry and custard pie.
They were sold out of that as well.
We have a strawberry
sundae, a caramel sundae,
and then we have
a Cadbury Flake soft serve.
Oh, my gosh, the Flake has
been consumed by the ice cream.
You can't even see the Flake anymore.
RIP.
We have our frozen Fanta
raspberry, frozen Fanta blueberry,
frozen Fanta mango, and
our frozen Fanta grape.
I really want to try this Milo McFlurry.
Literally what my dreams
have been made of.
This is unreal.
This is so yum.
Our only exclusive dessert option
is the chocolate chip cookies,
which I think in the realm
of fast-food cookies,
this is definitely at the top
because they stay soft and
they're actually pretty good.
A perfectly fine chocolate chip cookie.
Outside of McCafé drinks,
we have a couple of exclusive
soft drinks here in Australia.
We have a vanilla Coke,
we have a Coke zero,
and sparkling water.
While it's technically not an exclusive,
it's also worth noting that in Australia,
we call our milkshakes thickshakes.
The reason why we call
our milkshakes thickshakes
is because a milkshake is
different in Australia.
So, milkshake is literally
just a sweetened milk.
So if you were to get
a strawberry milkshake,
it would just be a really
thin strawberry-tasting milk.
With a thickshake, it's
a thicker consistency.
In front of me though,
I have the sweet tea,
the orange Hi-C,
and the two milk options that they offer,
which is regular and a chocolate milk.
Do not be fooled by this very
naturally occurring color.
It is not real fruit juice.
Hi-C is something entirely its own thing.
Australians love McDonald's,
or it's more commonly
known here as Macca's.
The nickname is so popular
that McDonald's has
actually leaned into it
and formally embraced it.
It's always called Macca's.
That being said, though,
it can get confusing,
as Macca can also refer
to anyone with a surname
that starts with M-C or Mac, M-A-C.
So McDonald's equals Macca's,
but Paul McCartney, for an
example, is also called Macca.
So the context is really crucial here.
McDonald's has the
second-highest number of stores
of any fast-food chain in Australia,
ranking just below Subway.
That number stands to rise too,
with reports saying that
McDonald's is planning to spend
a billion Australian dollars
opening and renovating
stores in the coming years.
Anecdotally, I think Macca's
is way more popular than Subway
just because it's convenient
and I think everyone
always craves a burger,
and I feel like the idea of Subway
isn't as appealing as McDonald's is.
There are over 13,000
locations here in the US,
so I think it's fair to say
that Americans love their McDonald's.
You can't go, like, a few miles
without seeing golden arches.
They are absolutely everywhere.
I don't know a single
person who's never tried it.
I don't think America has a national dish,
but if we did, I feel like it would be
a burger, fries, a
milkshake, and/or a soda.
Like, that's so American in my brain.
And that's why McDonald's in itself
feels like such an American food chain.
McDonald's Australia has
tried to adapt its menu
to local tastes over the years.
One of the examples was that
of the recent potato scallop controversy.
Yes, I know it sounds bizarre.
What is a potato scallop?
So many questions.
But in January of 2023,
Macca's announced a new menu item,
and it was called a potato
scallop with chicken salt.
So, this sparked an online debate,
as the states of Victoria and Tasmania
refer to this as a potato cake,
whereas other areas call
it a potato fritter.
Some claim that the name is
an insult to potato cakes.
To be honest, I don't care.
But so many Australians do,
and it is, like, institutionalized in them
that they need to care
about what a potato cake
is actually called.
Basically, if you also don't
know what a potato cake is,
it's literally just a deep-fried potato
with chicken salt on top of it.
And chicken salt is also
an Australian classic.
It's sadly not on the menu anymore.
So at least that debate can
be put on hold, for now.
In America, I would say that McDonald's
is pretty much exactly
the same everywhere.
I don't think that they adapt
to local tastes to that degree,
but they do vary from country to country.
So, for you Americans,
I have some hot tea to share with you.
So, basically somebody
said our prime minister
had s--- his pants at
Engadine McDonald's in 1997
after a football grand final.
It was such a popular response,
like so many people kept
on trolling him online,
like on Twitter, and just being like,
"Scott Morrison, did you
actually s--- your pants?"
And he would ignore it.
But eventually he went to an event,
I think it may have been a charity event,
and he had to address it,
but he left us in the lurch,
basically still saying
he can't confirm nor deny
if he s--- his pants
at McDonald's in 1997.
We need some closure, Scott Morrison.
If you're listening to this,
just tell us the truth.
The people have a right
to know this information.
We can't talk about McDonald's
and not mention the
McDonald's cast of characters.
Grimace just had his birthday,
in which we got a
celebratory Grimace shake.
It was OK.
But there's others like Ronald McDonald,
which, I feel like as a
kid he was such a big deal.
Nowadays, McDonald's doesn't
really push their characters
the way that they used to.
After a little bit of
digging, we found out that
McDonald's kind of took Ronald
out of the spotlight a bit
after the 2016 clown scare.
Do you guys remember this?
People were dressing up like clowns
to try to terrify people
with, like, weapons and stuff.
It was, like, a whole issue.
People were just doing it to
scare people, and they said,
"Ronald, unfortunately,
we're going to have to
sit you out for the rest of your life."
He's still on the cake, though.
He's still on the sheet cake,
so I think that counts for something.
Oh, the sheet cake we didn't get.
By the way, McDonald's has a sheet cake
that you can ask for.
They did try to phase the
characters back in in 2022
with the adult Happy Meal,
which featured all of the old characters.
But I don't know if they're taking off
as much as they did in the '90s.
A Big Mac in the US costs 13.8% more.
But if you go with a medium,
you'll be paying around
0.6% less in the US.
And a large Big Mac meal is 2.8% less
in the US.
Here's the nutrition of
our Australian Big Mac.
Here's the nutrition
breakdown of a US Big Mac.
We have more calories, fat, carbs,
sugar, and sodium, but less protein.
Interesting.
Our medium fries has 297 calories.
Our fries have more
calories and more carbs,
yet less sodium and less sugar.
That's actually a big shocker
that we have less sodium
because every time I've
gotten McDonald's fries
they are perfectly salty or overly salty.
Our medium Coke is 136 calories.
Our medium Coke has more calories,
but also the cup is bigger.
So, the total meal is
997 calories.
And the US total is 1,120 calories.
That's a 12.3% increase in the US.
Here are the ingredients
of an Australian Big Mac.
A key distinction between the
beef in Australia and the US
is the majority of cattle
in our country is grass-fed,
while in the US, beef is mostly grain-fed.
Grain-fed tends to have a bit more
of a uniform taste and texture,
whereas grass-fed is heavily influenced
by seasonal and regional factors,
resulting in a diverse range
of complex flavors and textures.
Additionally, the high concentration
of beta-carotene in grass
contributes to a more pronounced taste
in the fat found in grass-fed beef.
The taste can be quite different,
and Australians take pride in their meat.
A US Big Mac contains all of this.
A few things to note.
The pickle slices contain alum,
which is used to dissolve steel,
and polysorbate 80, which has
been linked to colon cancer.
This means we can cue the dancing mice.
Caramel color is on
California's list of chemicals
that may cause cancer or
reproductive toxicity.
One thing we want to note is
the quality of the US Big Mac
and McDonald's burgers in general.
In November, McDonald's
revamped how it cooks
and prepares its burgers,
including the Big Mac.
They've added more sauce,
upgraded to a buttery brioche bun,
the cheese is more melty, and
the vegetables are fresher.
There actually aren't very
many vegetables in this burger,
but the lettuce doesn't look wilted.
Like, it looks like fresh lettuce.
These are the ingredients in our fries,
which are vegan-friendly.
Woo-hoo!
Here's everything that's
in the McDonald's fries.
In the US, they are not vegan-friendly
because there is a beef
flavoring added in.
Whatever they're doing,
I'm sorry, it's working.
These fries are good.
And in Australia, our Coke is actually
made out of real sugar.
Whereas the US Coke contains
high-fructose corn syrup.
Ugh, I'm gonna eat you!
Scott Morrison, don't defame me!
I'm just reading what people have said!
I'm gonna take a bite of this table.
Conner: Hell yeah.
Ah!
That's a lot more inviting.
That looks like a demon burger
that I'm not ready to
eat right this second.